hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where right now i am catching
up on
the state of play from july 8. i've
actually pretty much
managed to steer clear of any spoilers
other than knowing that it has a lot of
death loop content
which anyone who's been watching my
channel will know i've been saying since
last year basically since it was
revealed that it's my most anticipated
game of this year
i love arcane i love dishonored i love
the whole vibe of the thing so i am down
to see more of it
but this is also a 30 minute conference
so i'm guessing we're getting more
than just death loop let's see shall we
yeah we streamed on july eight
so i'm a few days late but that's okay
there are those who look into the eyes
of another
and see opportunity
a soul to corrupt and twist
their stories are the ones we fear the
vr game
and there are those who see potential
the light within the soul
a chance to lift someone up to achieve
the impossible
moss was great that was really good rise
to legend
so tell me
[Music]
in quill
because her story yeah depends not that
i wasn't already sure
it was a really good game the setting
looks
similar-ish similar vibe very pretty
feel like the um
kind of my headphones down i feel like
the environments
look more detailed
seriously if you haven't played it it's
really good like dark soulsy in some
ways
hell yeah book two that's awesome
i'm actually genuinely stoked um
a really pleasant game puzzles like
almost god of warish
in a way moss 2 is very good
development for psvr we've got some more
exciting updates today so let's keep it
going
here's a flashy new multiplayer shooter
from the team at illfonic
oh i saw james tweet about this today is
this the game that uh
james will in toronto
[Music]
i'm not sure if elise did too i should
check that i only saw james's tweet i'm
not sure if elise
also did ex-colleagues of mine if you
don't know
i'm not sure i never have to ask
so this is gonna be a multiplayer
shooter
okay there you go
i'm gonna knock out city vibes for sure
do i imagine gameplay is pretty
different
just similar flavor
oh early access is up cool i'll check it
out sure why not
that was your first look at arcade to
get it which begins early access today
for playstation 5.
tribes of midgard arrives later this
month let's get a sneak peek at the
post-launch plans for this addictive
action rpg from norse fell games so this
is starting
hi i'm with sydney from norseville and
i'm here to tell you more about how
tribes of midgard will grow even bigger
after launch
and then finishing the season updates
tribes of midgard is a ten player
survival action rpg
where you play as an inheriar a
legendary viking warrior what a nice
games these days himself to stop
ragnarok there are two primary game
modes the session-based saga mode
and the endless survival mode that are
all about exploring midgard
powering up your character and
fortifying your home village
to stand against giants bent on
destroying the seat of ygdr's
new seasonal updates will change i'm
sure it should be fun and add challenges
for you and your tribe to overcome
the game launches with season one the
wolf saga
it includes new classes exclusive loot
and a powerful new boss
there will be eight different classes to
unlock and choose from
let's take a quick look at the ranger
one of our skill trees though
very easy levels you unlock
game-changing abilities yeah blowy i'm
guessing
like the lightning fast quick shot or
the powerful slow poke
because classes are complimentary it's
fun to have a bit of everything in your
tribe
we're excited to see how your strategies
will change as classes expand in future
updates
season one also introduces runes which
give you new special powers to customize
your character
this feels like a strange place to have
sega
you can use multiple runes together and
the effects can get pretty wild
you'll end up with different rune
combinations each session so you'll
always have new ways to experiment it
looks neat i'm sure i would enjoy
playing this
last but not least the biggest part of
every season are saga quests a series of
quests that will bring you across
midgard in season 1 saga
you'll unlock the ability to access a
mysterious lair and face down seriously
as you say challenge yet and the more
dangerous foes you take on
the greater the reward speaking of great
rewards the wolf sega is stacked with
season exclusive weapons
armor sets and truly mighty companions i
love this guy this saga is well
hello you're speaking my language keep
expanding with more seasons that explore
different parts of norse mythology
and add even more to the game thanks for
watching and we'll see you in midgard
soon on july 27th
cool july 27
oh gearbox hmm
port cities as good as lost
must you go back i must go back
in order to end all this
the environment oh my
okay
hmm
[Music]
i am um definitely playing that that was
the first one of these that i've been
like one thousand percent yes
[Music]
you get titties always
of the battles more titties look at them
wow
[Music]
it wouldn't be a fighting game or about
a royale without titties hi everyone
i'm john georgie from mantisco hello and
on behalf of our studio
i am thrilled to welcome you to the
world of hunters arena
it's an intriguing combination in this
mystical world you will play as hunters
who must fight deadly demons as well as
other online players in order to survive
as a skillful hunter you will master
powerful swordplay and martial arts
and will be constantly tested of your
skills of precise timing and fast
decision making i wonder if it um
functions like a um don't forget to have
a little fun on your journey by
customizing your weapons from disco
balls to rubber ducks
that ubisoft explore our expensive maps
you will be able to explore dungeons
and yeah look forward to seeing you hack
at them and you have the stances
cannot remember the name of the game
another huge threat to look out for is
none other than what that's
always have different strategies in mind
and use the environment around you when
facing your enemies
utilize bushes for ambush or drop strike
from higher grounds to unleash a lethal
blow on
unexpecting enemy players
i don't feel like this is battle royale
arena features two battle royale modes
okay
sorry and solomo sorry about that it
will slowly take on other enemy players
as well as deadly demons lurking behind
your back in a 30 player free-for-all
in trio mode you'll be able to team up
with your friends where focusing on
teamwork and planning out strategies are
crucial in achieving victory
there is so much more to experience in
this fascinating world
i cannot wait for you to encounter the
countless dangers waiting in hunters
arena when it launches
next month on ps4 and ps5
also looks pretty cool to me thank you
for joining me today
and i will again definitely playing fist
hunters um but all of the other games
have been like
why the [ __ ] with that jumped into not
like intensely hyped but i'm like yeah i
checked that out i realized on ps4 and
ps5 next month
that could be fun playstation plus
members will be able to download the ps4
and ps5 versions at no extra cost
starting august 3rd i've destroyed my
back today
sit real weird oh my god i want this
game
so bad it looks so cool
i didn't know there was more gameplay of
it
it's like obviously the combat of this
game sifu i think that's how you
pronounce it it's very akin to
you know awkward um and i don't think
it's trying not to do that but the
setting is just so stylish
i'm also like getting sort of more
hotline miami but in third person ish
vibes
and i think that you play as different
family members
i love the setting yeah
i mean i love the challenge rooms in the
awesome games where it was just fighting
like 100 people if this is more of that
i'm down
[Music]
ah it looks so good when does it come
out
damn that's okay
make good game take lot time ever wanted
to explore an
alien planet then this next game is for
you
i guess i wouldn't say no
no man sky is it no it's not
it's like if that zooms in a bit further
it could be it's not
this is jet the far shore created by
super brothers and pine scented
with a score by scientific
in chat you play as may one of a unit of
aviator scientists
who embark on an interstellar trip and a
light on a mythic
ocean planet with a dream of securing a
future
for their species so is the gameplay you
can walk around
or is it just [ __ ] to create a video
game to express our own
feelings of awe when we look up the
lighting in this video so bad i'm so
sorry everyone
not much i can do jet is all about
motion whether it's weaving through
trees
or jumping over obstacles okay
i love that sense of speeding through a
remarkable natural space under a grand
sky
and suddenly being in someone's helmet
boots on the ground oh there you go
jet's premise involves exploration and
discovery
however our design doesn't rely on
combat or
resource extraction which is a very the
characters go to some
destiny ui giving indigenous wildlife
a wide berth striving to adapt
and avoid conflict as a jet scout
you'll inspect living things and employ
your jets
tools to figure out what makes them tick
occasionally you'll run into trouble and
you'll have to use
everything at your disposal to emerge
unscathed
over the years we've contemplated what
might be on the minds of interstellar
explorers
what might propel them and what might
haunt them
and so our story provides an occasional
glimpse into
may's dreams memories and visions
at heart jet is a laid-back
and enjoyable exploratory action
adventure
set within an intro don't really feel
like i know what this necessarily
is i like the music though
jet has had a long road for a few years
i feel like you're probably mostly
three of us since i'm flying oh my god
this vision has been
sharpened and that's amazing bolstered
by an all-star squad
oh okay it's big enough you'll embark
with us
i'm very curious but unclear
and i also i wonder if it was an ask
that um
all of these trailers have bo because i
feel like sometimes it's maybe a little
bit better that
for new games unless you've just not
heard of this game like don't do that
let's check in with our friends at sega
for more on two upcoming adventures
this is definitely not sonic about three
days ago
a body turned up in yokohama oh
maybe you hadn't heard that
oh is this um the game made by um
yakuza devs
you mean it's revenge in that case yeah
it is
um they've hired someone else to kill
the guy in his step lost judgment
do you think it's called we've seen this
game before
and it does look like his murder is too
suspicious very yakuza
which i'm very much okay with because
yakuza is suspicious
okay it's cool
wonderful and um i i just took up my
sentence so i didn't force myself in the
middle of it
all right got mini games look at you
guys
okay i believe in you buddy
oh my that's like such a great mix of
very serious and extremely ridiculous
i'm just as clueless as you are and um
this confirms that
this game again i think it's lost
judgment is uh
your final right down with that vibe
i guess we couldn't ask for a better
piece of bait what the hell do you think
you're doing
this has nothing to do with her stop
come on
this game looks dope oh my
as you do yeah love it
judgment it is yes
good yes oh cool
i don't think i knew that maybe i did i
always forget revealed just a few weeks
ago
time for a closer look at the expanded
and enhanced death
stranding director's cut coming soon to
ps5
was it announced just a few weeks ago i
guess it kind of once there was an
explosion
a bang which gave rise to life as we
know i'm curious
about what this director's cut will
entail and also about the fact that the
original death training wasn't already a
direct discussion explosion
an explosion i wouldn't think kojima
productions had many people telling
kojima what to cut
sam i'll be waiting for you on the beach
you're building americans get rid of the
bts
but at least we'll have hope i do think
no matter what death training is worth
trying
and this seems like probably the best
way to get anything interesting to see
reviews if people like it more or less
you see i've come to understand the
truth
is that troy baker
[Music]
oh yeah
loves the firing range
cool cool love that
um
[Music]
[Music]
i'll be waiting for you on the beach
hmm
i'm curious to see what people think of
it it's um it's an interesting thing to
do i'm surprised that again
the original version wasn't just the
director's cut or is this just like a
way of saying like game of the year
edition like it has more content
death lube hits ps5 on september 14th
yes it does check out an extended game i
would love to know of bethesda and
arcane's violent vision i'm really
excited about this game
because it does really look like this on
it which i am okay with
[Music]
but with this like bioshocky style that
i love
and then the looped mechanic is very hit
man
like figuring out where people are how
are you going to kill them
i love i love the idea i feel like
everybody else is asleep on this game
it's totally normal death is a typical
physiological experience in this place
i hate to break it to you but there is
nothing normal
about this [ __ ] island oh [ __ ]
you're gonna get i wonder how long it's
gonna be like campaign-wise
be very curious about that which means i
already know what's going to happen
am i supposed to do this every day for
the rest of my life
[ __ ] that i'm breaking this loop i'm
dinga game director
at arcane leon and i'm here to give you
a special look
at this loop yes please you are cold
you're stuck in a time loop on the
island of black reef where everybody
wants you dead
to escape you have to take out eight
targets known as the visionaries before
the day repeats
also one of your targets also
business of hunting you down
fail to kill the targets or die
and the day starts over oh gotta be
kidding me
but every loop is an opportunity with
every cycle you will learn more about
the visionaries and the secrets of the
island by exploring and observing
you will discover their habits and
secrets using that knowledge to progress
through the story
let's jump into a mission several hours
into the game
called take on the visionary alexis the
wolf
dorsey so what does the mission mean
like isn't the whole mission already
before us
plans to give us or are they individual
well guarded masquerade party
oh by mission do you mean intel it's
like an intel thing like hitman take him
down
i was just thinking i want to know what
the [ __ ] is going on oh you don't want
that
you're looking for a purpose i'm looking
for the fastest way out of this place
there are rules and sometimes people
bend the rules
and sometimes they break them blah blah
blah
are you talking when i was talking i
have top secret information straight up
blink
what is it which we kind of already knew
very good very good very good i feel
like this game probably won't have any
punishment for killing people like it's
not owned
i've thought about it like dishonored
does that i think i'm doing
everyone here a favor by ending this so
what happens when you break the loop
seriously i want your theories
everything goes back to normal obviously
normal you have absolutely no [ __ ]
idea what will happen
true but i know one way to find out
dying isn't the end reprise is one yeah
it's probably pretty easy to die
it allows you to die and rewind twice
before the loop restarts you have also
seen carnesis that allows you to yank
enemies around
and shifts the short range table so if
you die three times the lip rests no
matter what
the whole loop the whole game or just
like a mission
[Music]
[Applause]
i've intentionally knocked um like i've
watched
all the deathly stuff in the state of
plays but i've not
read any previews because the truth is
that i don't know that i want any of
these questions that i have answered
i've not actually researched heroes
we're called
to regain residium a resource that
allows you to save your favorite weapons
and abilities between loops
over time you will build an arsenal of
weapons that's very likely it is an
upgrade
that you can mix and match between
missions to suit your playstyle
all the needs of it what is between
missions mean my point is i'm watching
these gameplay videos stoked about this
game but i don't think i want the
answers to all of my questions
i'm actively not going any extra mile to
research it
i will take it as fresh as i can get it
really um but i'm not going to stop
myself from watching it in a
state of play we use the haptic feedback
and the adaptive trigger of the ps5
every movement feels different and
weapons express their personality
in the palm of your hands
[Music]
that was cool
i'm down to do that don't stop there put
them both together
the body count is gonna get high
there's always multiple ways to approach
a target and we just learned of one
the back entrance to the mansion
conversations like this happen all over
black reef and it often pays to stop and
listen
[Music]
hmm
the map seems pretty significant i'll
say that much
cool
and i wonder what the the glowing text
on the ui
i'm sure arcane would have a low reason
for that and i'm sure it's there it's
not just for this demo
that alert means your rival juliana god
i love dishonored
it's so good dishonored too specifically
like what i'm thinking while watching
this is like
when she's on the damn arcade
it's like you know when you know
something's just gonna slap
you liked the party wow my style uh
you're all business all the time aren't
you
what is your style exactly
when i should be killing [ __ ]
apparently
[Music]
[Music]
the wolves play a sixth game whoever
fails to impress the others with their
evil deeds
goes into the grinder and onto the
dinner menu
let's see if we can read the outcome am
i
i wonder if other people on this island
know they're stuck in a loop surely some
of them do
they're eating each other there's a lot
to unpack here
yikes
what's up but it could also be another
masked speaker
so let's hear him out and don't take the
shots
lawsuits whatever what would be the
downside which is killing everybody
we made millions that year
who died
arrogant cruel no regard for others
yeah that's definitely alexis
aliop alexis just dropped an upgrade to
the carnacy's power
and a hefty dose of residue time to get
the hell out of him
i hope this music actually plays that is
my go-to move and dishonored
i will just jump on the high thing
[Music]
the gunplay looks pretty good
[Music]
my god this is so stylish
so you definitely live through like more
enemies than i would have thought there
oh you left a ton of people
in your wick
[Music]
why wasn't i
[Music]
[Applause]
you're invited call me like this all the
time julie julie
i give approximately zero [ __ ] about
what you call yourself
but you did once
okay that's it though show me no more of
this game stop
i'm doing it stop showing it to me
um i'm very excited that's a wrap for
today
okay breaking
there's a certain point where it's like
too much you know what i'm saying
so that was um that was a strange day to
play like just an unusual format i feel
like different to the others
um happy to see death loop happy to see
more of sifu and of lost judgment
um ton of solid games in there mass 2 is
really cool definitely play the first
moss if you haven't already
um but yeah i'm at a point now where i
could be saturated with
with death loop i could see too much of
it
and again if you keep putting them in
the state of plays i'm going to keep
watching them
so just i'm i'm good now obviously
personal preference but that's how i
feel about it
um all right thank you all for watching
sorry about the terrible lighting it is
bad
it's just because there's a light right
above my head there's
not much i can do about that i'll see
you guys next time
bye